[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
chief leader writer at The Observer
Sonia soda and the CEO of total politics
group Mark Wallace welcome to both of
you so as ever let's take a look shall
we at the front pages starting with the
daily mail it leads with police fears
that the baby of constance Martin and
Mark Gordon has come to harm after the
pair were arrested on Monday night
leading the Daily Express tomorrow is
rishi's brexit boost for the UK which
celebrates the new deal with the
European Union the eye reporting on the
new brexit agreement on Northern Ireland
their headlines sunac gambles his
political career on defying the brexit
deal critics the Ft leads with a report
that Jaguar Land Rover owner Tata Motors
is demanding more than 500 million
pounds of from the government of
government Aid rather to to build a new
battery Factory in Britain
Arms Of Love writes The Daily Mirror
reporting on a story of a father who can
finally hold his twin daughters again
after a double hand transplant
and the Daily Star has a story on the
price of veg for Market Traders as they
say the salad crisis worsens well a
reminder by scanning the QR code you'll
see on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let's
head straight to Sonia soda and Mark
Wallace and Sonia let's go to the Daily
Mail shall we
um the real concerns now about this
um a two-month-old baby and this massive
search underway near Brighton now real
concern
it's such a worrying story Anna so it's
a couple who went missing with their
baby very shortly after they had their
newborn in early January they've been on
the run for over 50 days uh have been a
lot of concerns about where they are and
what's happened to them and um the
couple have been found but without the
baby and they've now been arrested on
the suspicion of Grace negligence
manslaughter so it's obviously a live
case we can't say anything
um to Prejudice their right to a free
trial uh Fair trial rather but it's
really really worrying um that the baby
wasn't found with them we know very
little about the baby we don't even know
whether it's a boy or a girl the police
are clearly extremely worried
um because the weather's very cold and
they're not sure where the baby is
whether it might be outside and
explosity elements so it's a massive
search underway and um it's just you
know I think it's just one of those
stories where you read and you just sort
of hope and pray say that the little
baby is okay but the truth is we just
don't know yes the prospect possibly
that the baby's being looked after by
someone else you know they're holding
out for that but we saw the pictures
there mark this search area is
absolutely vast
um a corridor of seven miles by 13 miles
from 91 square miles to be searched on
on the Sonia said a really cold night
indeed and you can see I think in in the
footage there in the coverage and you
know the coverage we see in the
newspapers today but also what we've
seen of this story and this search for
this couple cropping up over the last 50
something days intermittent you can see
the level of resource that's been put in
that is very illustrative of the level
of official concern evidently by the
officers and others involved in this
case in this search
quite what may have happened you know I
I think you'll be wrong for us to
speculate particularly Estonia says
given this is a a uh a live
investigation
charges and so on uh potentially during
the rounds but I I don't really
concerning case in itself and I think
you can see as I say when when this
story from when it first broke that the
police have ever been very very
concerned at each stage absolutely and
uh as Sonya was suggesting there the
couple not cooperating uh haven't even
revealed the gender of the baby so we
watch we wait and uh we hope don't we
let's move on Mark I'm going to stay
with you if you don't mind your reaction
to the meetings that we've seen this
evening uh Rishi sunak speaking to back
bench MPS we've seen the European
research group of Tory brexiteers
meeting alongside the dup you know where
are we at if we look at the eyes soon
that gambles his political career on
defying those brexit deal critics so
he's going to go ahead with this come
what may that's the suggestion from
Downing Street
well where we are in this is the prime
minister is engaged in a battle for
hearts and Minds obviously there are a
variety of different groups and
audiences The Wider uh electorates at
large is obviously absolutely crucial to
that people who are skeptical of brexit
is very important to that too but one
part of that electoral Coalition that he
has to try and pull together and swing
behind his uh deal the The Windsor deal
is the levers that breaks tears and it's
the fate of a prime minister that you
can't choose the steps that were taken
by your predecessors and the fact is
that all the way back to referendum
itself through uh particularly to the
Theresa May era
um there have been a variety of times
when brexiteers of all parties are known
and also Northern Irish unionists and
particularly the dup feel like they've
had their fingers burned feel like
they've been asked to trust one thing
and have an essay been able to do so
they feel let down and that
do no followed Rishi sunax has left um a
position in which people are extremely
wary so what's interesting is we're
hearing the ERG and some others are not
going to bring forward their opinion for
potentially up to a fortnight formerly
because they're taking detailed legal
advice on exactly not just the UK text
in English of this deal but what the
eu's own published version of course
which may differ from their own
interpret you know their interpretation
May differ from what they what Downing
Street says they're taking their time
they're taking advice because they want
that reassurance the Prime Minister
evidently intends to use that time to
Bang the Drum to go and press the flash
to go around and talk to people is
interesting
um you know as an event in Westminster
earlier this evening where Steve Baker
now a minister former chairman of the
ERG
um
lifelong kind of long-standing call
brexit here was um was there telling
people this is the best deal that's
going to be available this is the best
deal that should be there that that
could be there that's why I'm behind it
and so there's a lot of that persuading
to do but there's um there's a lot of
you know painful history in recent years
for him to overcome yes Steve Baker
talking about the personal toll on him
of uh of these years of what's felt like
battle I suppose uh Mark fourso are
telling us tonight coming out of that
meeting uh they're going to take two
weeks they've appointed their Star
Chamber to pour of the details uh the
eye um saying that uh the dup they're
going to take time to mull over it and
they're going to be seen to take time to
mull over it obviously um the problem is
some people are a little bit skeptical
because the dup you know would head back
into store not as Top Dog it was Sinn
Fein
um that won the last election
effectively Sonia they would go back as
first Minister and some people are
signing some reluctance on the dup for
for that reason so you know they've got
a lot to think about
I think we just have to hope that they
get there because I honestly think this
is um the best compromise we're ever
going to
oh I think she's Frozen hello Sonia
yeah I was just gonna say well I think
we have to really hope that the dep come
along with this because I think it's the
best compromise we're going to get I
think Missy sunak um you know to his
credit in many ways I'm no fan of what
she's seen that normally but he took a
very different negotiating approach to
Boris Johnson I think he um created the
relationship of trust with Ursula Von
delayan and
um you know fellow leaders political
leaders like macron across the EU and I
think this deal is genuinely As Good As
It Gets he's managed to get things that
didn't look like they were on the table
three years ago under Bryce Johnson's
Premiership so we do have Customs checks
down the Irish sea but um the deal finds
a way of minimizing them EU legislation
and regulations do apply in Northern
Ireland but there is this so-called
stormant look which means that um the
the storm assembly have an appropriate
veto power if it transpires that
proposed EU regulations might have
significant negative uh context and uh
consequences and and you would have to
have a period where basically the
Republic of Ireland the UK government
and the EU go into negotiations with
each other so I think it really you know
there's there's no way of fully solving
the brexit conundrum when it comes to
Northern Ireland and this deal is as
good it's gonna as it's gonna get so I
think we just have to hope that the dep
come along
yes the Daily Express as well Mark
rishi's brexit boost for the UK I mean
is he in danger of overselling this he
talks about this unique position that
Northern Ireland was in with the
benefits of the internal Market of the
UK and the single Market of the European
Union which everyone pointed out sounded
very much like the benefits of us being
in the European Union so you know and
how does that go down with the dup who
were the the group that did not want um
us to stay in uh the EU
well I think there's a little bit of
clever clever kind of Point scoring
sometimes when people come out with
stuff like that it's a little bit when
um a little bit like when Liz trust was
talking recently about the idea of a
kind of wider Alliance of uh of Western
Democratic states with shared values and
various people kind of chin stroke and
said oh lol isn't that the same as the
EU well it's not I mean the fact is that
you know whether what we're talking
about here particularly of course what's
interesting which no one really is very
into saying I think on either side of
this is this is essentially a kind of
potential settlement for Northern
Ireland that the EU would never be
willing to offer to the UK as a whole so
it is an unusual position what's
interesting about this Express story is
of course the express is a it became I
think the first vocal uh brexit
newspaper they were the first newspaper
to support the better off our campaign
um they are coming out pretty heavily
for this I do think that there are risks
for the prime minister in this obviously
he's decided that so he needs to grasp
the nettle on he's decided something
where he wants to effectively revisit
the power of that message back in 2019
of get brexit done the reason why it was
quite a clever message is it worked for
two different it it provided one answer
to two different sets of Voters people
who really supported brexit and wanted
to see it through felt like it had been
thwarted and frustrated but also people
who were themselves frustrated who were
bored and the redditors get brings it
over
um and he's kind of returning to that a
little bit I think by saying well you
know this is the opportunity if you're
tired of this brings it here or or
Auntie brexit here this is what I think
is a sustainable way through it there is
a risk for him which is that if he sells
it very warmly as his responsibility and
then people look under the hood
um there's an interesting article by
Barrister Stephen Barrett I think in
published by The Spectator this evening
which starts to question whether it's
quite as glowing as it's made out to be
there's a danger that people who are
already a bit burned by this process
might feel that perhaps there's it's got
a bit more polished than it deserves but
we shall see what happens when he goes
on this as he goes around this campaign
yeah I suppose the point is it's an
improvement you know whether there's
bits that need um you know that are not
100 perfect I've got the times as well
now Sonia deal is not negotiable soon
act tells the dup suggesting they'll
push ahead without them and then the
paper goes on to say the unionist
sources said the party's officers who
will make a decision on its position
were split with members of the Stormont
assembly more strongly in favor of
returning to power sharing while the
party's MPS in Westminster took a harder
line so we wait to see on that I just
wanted to talk about styles of
leadership though the contrast with
Rishi sunak who's managed to get this
deal and the way he
um now has this relationship with the
European Union which may unlock other
matters
um and also this idea that he's a
cleaner upper he cleans up after the the
mess of Liz truss he's cleaned up after
the years of the Northern Ireland
protocol and all that came with it and
whether this one-man bandwagon is enough
to change the fortunes of the election
or if he might run out of time or the
hope is lost what do you think
I'm not so sure about enough to sort of
turn the conservative electoral fortunes
around I think sadly actually not that
there isn't even enough awareness of the
issues that brexit has had in relation
to Northern Ireland across the country
and I'm not sure that it's very high
salience in terms of the way that voters
will uh vote although you know it's
possible that people will look at this
and say well you know he can get things
done and and he stands in contrast quite
frankly I think the conservatives
electoral fortunes will be determined by
the state of the economy
um in the next couple of years and um
you know there is a chance that it turns
around but things aren't looking that
great it has to be said when you look at
our grave forecasts
um I do think however that CNAC has a
very different style of leadership to
Boris Johnson and I think Boris Johnson
and Lord Frost um who you know took the
lead on brexit negotiations they went in
with very divisive tactics um they
weren't really interested in building a
trusted relationship uh there was a lot
of briefing to the British us about how
terrible the EU was and how Britain was
just going to get its way and I just
don't think it works when it comes to
these types of negotiations and I think
sunak has shown that quite frankly okay
it's a it's a massive area to talk about
isn't it all of that but we move on and
coming up after the break we will have
the latest on the reaction to the
transgender rapist jailed for eight
years back in just a moment
[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview with
me once again the chief leader writer
The Observers on new soda and the CEO of
total politics group Mark Wallace uh
Sonny I'm going to go to you if you
don't mind the transgender rapist uh
Ferrari around which uh possibly
contributed to the demise of Nicholas
sturgeon has been jailed for eight years
and is heading to air man's jail or
men's jail
yes and quite right too I think so this
is the male rapist who used to be known
as Adam Graham now says that he
identifies as a woman and calls himself
Isla Bryson
um it caused a huge political Fury in
Scotland because it came just after the
passage of the gender reform recognition
act that is backed by the SMP but had
some support from other parties and this
was essentially legislation that said
that anybody can change their legal sex
on the basis of self-declaration and
that essentially means that any man who
says that there are women that they
identify as a woman can change their sex
to female for legal purposes which
confers extra legal rights of access to
women's single sex spaces Hospital
Awards prisons Single Sex Sports so
there was huge concern in Scotland about
this act and
um you know all the paling evidence
suggests that Scottish public were
against it it's also it was consequent
it was blocked by the um British by the
Westminster government following the
passage of the legislation
um because the Westminster government
used the Scotland that and they said
that it would affect the operation of
the equality act uk-wide which is
Westminster law that's determined by
Westminster not by Hollywood
but it's also how political consequences
in Westminster so Dominic Robb the
Justice secretary has now made it very
clear that unless ministers overturn it
uh males who are convicted of sex
offenses or who have male genitalia
cannot be housed in female prisons
simply because they say they identify as
women I think that's absolutely right
but actually I think that there's no
place for males in female only prisons
prisons are female only for really
important reasons both from a safety
perspective they contain some of the
most vulnerable women in society the
majority of women in female prisons are
victims of domestic abuse but also from
a dignity and privacy perspective so
women who are incarcerated should not
have to share showers they should not
have to share sales with people who are
male so I think Rob's announcement goes
some way to answer those concerns from
many women across the UK but not fully
okay I know it's something that you feel
very passionately about certainly Mark
I'm going to move on if you don't mind
though I know you probably want to come
in on that the papers are dated March
the 1st which means we're 15 days away
from the budget you can start to feel
the pressure on all sorts of areas on
Jeremy Hunt including in the Daily
Express that suggests that precious
mounting on Jeremy Hunt to give
pensioners a budget boost as alarming
figures reveal annual incomes for over
60s with jobs have plummeted by nearly 3
000 pounds that and an energy rise as
well pressure on that too so really
we've got two weeks of coverage uh
trying to put the pressure on what hunt
might say come March the 15th
on pressure on every front I would say
very briefly on that previous Story one
thing Sonya didn't mention is I think
this had people not been willing to say
actually that there are real issues real
dangers and risks
um around failing to resolve this clash
between dogma and reality as reflected
in that case had people not be willing
to stick their necks out I don't think
reality and truth would have been able
to reassert itself and Sonia is actually
one of those people who stuck their neck
out and took an awful lot of quite
unpleasant bile from various courses for
doing so is to her and many others
credit but they they did so on that case
um on on this the the challenge facing
the chancellor in the next couple of
weeks
um you always see particularly at a cost
of living crisis facing you know such
high inflation as we've seen the last
few months a great amount of pressure on
a Chancellor from all sorts of angles as
to exactly where very limited resources
should be allocated what's really
interesting of course uh and you know
expect the government to talk this down
for now is that the forecasts on what
the cost of various energy G policies
the energy price guarantee and very
support policies we're going to be back
in September October those forecasts
have turned out to be much higher than
the real the real cost so it may well be
that the chancellor has much more or
quite a lot more sizable riddle room
then he might otherwise have expected
he's been telling us on corporation tax
and various other spending and spending
policies as well but he doesn't think
it's responsible to do things other than
deficit reduction it's going to be very
interesting to see whether he does that
or whether he sticks to that or whether
he finds specific measures on tax or
spending uh to what people might be able
to directly take action
we could do a whole program on what's to
come I think probably both of you thank
you very much indeed Mark Sonia lovely
to have you on thank you see you in the
last